this video is sponsored by the financial
wellness app acorns click the link in
the description and begin investing with
acorns today
there are so many reasons to be angry
we live in a culture that makes idealism
its goal and a world that makes idealism
impossible
there is so much wrong with others with
our self with the way things are
we reside somewhere inside a brain
watching and feeling its fervent
insatiable efforts to try and make the
world go its way and every day with as
little as the sound of a car horn or a
lost set of keys we are reminded that
this is an impossibility
that we are stuck between the awareness
of a god and the temperament of an
animal
often anger just makes a lot of sense
of course there are different types of
anger different instances and sources
different temperaments with different
propensities toward it and arguably in
many cases anger can be a very useful
emotion it can be a source of insight
into when we've been wronged when things
are going poorly when we want change it
can be a source of character of
creativity of motivation of strength
but in other cases arguably far more
often it can also be a source of
foolishness of miscalculation of regret
of resentment of detachment from others
and from ourselves
we so often take personally what the
world does without us in mind
certainly we can be wronged in ways that
are unjust targeted correctable or
preventable and in these cases anger can
and likely should be used as a source of
motivation and force to recognize this
stand up and defend ourselves but
arguably more often we are wronged by
the world in ways where no amount of
angered force will help correct or solve
it
human existence is so unbelievably
absurd and chaotic and strange it is a
wonder it works in our favor at all any
of the time
we are lodged inside a clump of soft
tissue that we don't even understand
experiencing a reality made of particles
that we can't perceive all made and
governed by a universe that operates in
chaotic contradiction to the meaningful
order we so desperately desire the very
same desire the universe forced onto us
we were set up destined to have
everything fall over and over
we can tend to resist and reject any
sort of softer acceptance and sadness in
response to this and instead many of us
can become calloused over with a sort of
brute and frequent anger
this has its place in purpose but at a
certain point like a callous on the hand
we can become numb and unfeeling less
able to properly know and deal with the
truer conditions of our circumstances
those who are often angered reveal to be
a strange sort of optimist still in
denial of the tragedies of this life and
the death of their youthful innocence
the belief that life can be what it
can't
despite all evidence we are if we are
this in some non-traditional way still
hopeful hopeful that things should and
will go well in our favor most of the
time and thus we are constantly angered
by life's incongruency
we become angry about everything because
we refuse to let ourselves be sad about
some things
a theory in psychology known as
appraisal theory initially developed by
psychologist magna arnold suggests that
our emotional responses are in large
part created by our conscious
evaluations of events how we view
interpret and label stimuli rather than
the stimuli themselves
in other words in between our primary
experience of an event and our emotional
experience of an event there is a
filtering process that occurs through
and based on our cognitive faculties in
this space what we think based on our
experiences perceptions views and values
determines what we feel
for example if we have a fondness for
cats and believe cats are sweet and
harmless seeing or holding a particular
one will likely be a favorable emotional
experience
however for someone who believes cats
are threatening or devious this
experience will likely be a negative one
the emotional responses will be
completely different while the stimulus
remains the exact same
of course since our emotions are so
wide-ranging complicated and partly
rooted in consciousness a topic largely
uncracked by science a comprehensive
understanding of our emotions is still
yet to be seen and this model remains a
theory
and even in the case that this theory is
correct some of our appraisals will
still likely be more unconscious and
immediate than others making them harder
if not potentially impossible to get
into and control and perhaps sometimes
for good reason
however it is still fair to argue that
in many cases often the more common
cases the concept suggested by appraisal
theory has immense value and practical
use
especially when we are angered
frequently or remain angered for long
drawn out periods of time there is
likely large opportunity to change out
our mental filter in favor of better
more productive emotional experiences
in the words of american author david
foster wallace
learning how to think really means
learning how to exercise some control
over how and what you think it means
being conscious and aware enough to
choose what you pay attention to and to
choose how you construct meaning from
experience because if you cannot or will
not exercise this kind of choice in life
you will be totally hosed
this idea also coincides with principles
central to the philosophy of stoicism
for the stoics events in the world are
objective and neutral and our
qualitative emotional experiences are
merely a product of the narratives we
tell ourselves
it doesn't hurt me unless i interpret
it's happening as harmful to me
i can choose not to wrote marcus
aurelius
perhaps what we need then during those
moments of opportunity to reflect
mindfully on events and determine our
evaluations is to inject healthy but
sufficient doses of a sort of pessimism
and compassion
when we believe the world is congenial
and manageable in some just way when we
think we are at the center of all things
and all events in the world that happen
to us happen at us when we neglect to
consider that suffering and ignorance
are fundamental to all people anger can
and likely will eat us alive
rather if we realize that the world has
not singled us out then most people are
good people trying their best that
ignorance is far more often behind the
curtain and not malice that our emotions
are not the result of being made victim
by others but by us not taking ownership
of them ourselves
that life is inherently difficult and
suffering is fundamental to everyone we
can perhaps at least at times more
accurately evaluate if what we are
angered by is worthy of being angry
about and how
of course none of this is to say that we
should be or live an agreeable life in
which our anger is always denied of its
expression nor is it to say that we
shouldn't have expectations and make
effort to control and react to
circumstances to the best of our ability
but it is to say that often anger comes
from a place that isn't angry about the
thing we seem to be angry about that
anger is often a liability and not an
asset and that we aren't locked into
falling victim to it by always letting
ourselves think that we have personally
been made victim by the world
in the words of marcus aurelius
understand at last that you have
something in you more powerful and
divine than what causes the bodily
passions and pulls you like a mere
puppet
all of this might sound perfectly
reasonable useful and insightful but of
course that is until you get angry it is
then that all of this likely sounds
impossible nonsensical cheap or trite
but perhaps it is then and for this
reason especially that these ideas
matter so much the fact that we can
become so detached from our faculties of
reason and wisdom and that anger can
take us so far from what we truly think
and want
this video was sponsored by acorns
of course there was a lot to worry about
in life but there are a lot of areas
within our control that we can and
should try to be on top of that may help
reduce life's volatility and maintain as
favorable of conditions as possible
one area especially that is fundamental
to our quality of life is our financial
well-being getting a hold of your
finances through the habit of saving and
investing can be the difference between
having a harder or easier time managing
and improving other aspects of life for
many of us however the idea of investing
can be overwhelming and intimidating the
financial wellness app acorns however
makes the entire process of investing
easy and accessible for everyone in just
5 minutes you can sign up with acorns
and begin easily investing in the
background of your life with as little
as five dollars select from diversified
portfolios designed by experts according
to factors like your age and risk
tolerance and begin making individual or
recurring investments every day week or
month
there is no expertise required with
acorns and you can essentially just set
it up and let acorns do most of the work
if you're interested and want to start
building toward financial goals that can
have long-term impact go to
get.acorns.com pursuit of wonder or
click the link in the description below
and download acorns today by using my
link to set up an account you'll also
receive a 10 bonus investment terms and
conditions apply
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
you